oh yeah
dude i know that everybody's excited as
soon as they saw this
no way pontius on wild ride with stevo
i mean is that the fastest he ever
clicked this podcast
probably and so i'm not going to waste
any time let's dive into it
my bro ladies and gentlemen
chris pontius yeah dude
hello i'm delighted to be here i think
um
let's start off by talking um some up
close and personal
um private um inner thoughts about some
of the people that we work with
who should we start with right i was
gonna start that way because um
i'll tell you this is episode number
this will be 29 29 episode number 29
and you're only the third jackass guy
but the other two
jackass guys really crushed
i don't think yeah i i don't think that
uh anybody can crush harder than chris
pontius
i think he's gonna be the best yeah but
you guys have such a history and so much
to
that like you guys are the closest
members probably right like
yeah the wild boys experience really
brought you guys close together
yeah yeah i mean dude this is gonna be a
a humongous episode it's it's just
absolutely a hit already
and you know and i i gotta say too
that of the jackass guys
from the beginning i was always very
very jealous of chris pontius
and i would say putting a lump chris in
with brandon d camillo too
because they were hilarious naturally
funny
you know for me i was not naturally
funny man
won't i i i don't think i was dude i was
so
uncomfortable and i was just like i you
know
i felt like i had to like really [ __ ]
myself up in order to
to get laughs or to get footage and and
pawnee's just
it just came so naturally comedy just
flowed out of him
like just he could just talk and the
footage would be gold just talking
like for me just talking was never going
to be rad
and so yeah i always looked up to you
for that chris
hey thank you i'm i'm i'm flattered and
and i really am and but i'd like to
correct something
on for the record now i'm i over the
years every once in a while i see some
jackass facts and it'll be like
um when when chris first met stevo he
didn't initially like stevo
that was a total lie like i actually did
like and i i don't even know if i don't
think you believed that but
i did like you when i first met you when
did you guys meet
um in florida um i did like you
i think there was a thing when you were
boxing with ryan dunn where i was like
stevo
i don't like the man um i hope ryan wins
or something like that like
it was like something like that and then
some other thing it was one of those
things that got way blown out of
proportion
but i did like you when i first met you
and i wanted everyone listening to know
that
that uh yeah it was just an incorrect
fact all right and it bothered me
well i appreciate that and i remember it
well and thank you for asking paul
pontius and i met
for the first time when jackass
had been ordered to series it was it was
it started out as a pilot
and then when uh when i first filmed for
the series
i was still working in the circus and
pontius came with jeff tremaine with
johnny knoxville with the whole mtv
crew they filmed me in the circus that
day i
uh swallowed the goldfish then that
night we stapled
the letters of jackass under my butt
cheeks and then after
uh after filming after the bar
the wee hours of the morning pontius and
i went to a diner
ah i hope it was at ihop okay
the international house of pancakes yeah
absolutely it was far
like i was hungry i think i suggested it
but we ended up walking there
right and wherever that that was but god
it was far it wasn't
you know yeah it was it was somewhere at
that point we were down in miami and it
was still that very first night
yeah i ordered the um um root and tutti
fresh and fruity
strawberry pancakes you remember that
yeah
well that's what i always order when i
go
here's what i do remember is that uh
while we were eating
at ihop i i you know and this is after
the longest [ __ ] day and then getting
drunk
and then i mean who knows what time it
was and uh i'm telling like the the
waitress everybody in the ihop
hey you want to see a trick you're going
to see let me do a back flip let me do
like uh i'll
put a cup on my head and i'll drink it
with no hands i don't know and pontius
is just like
dude like stop stop
oh yeah like we got back and like we
were at the hotel on the balcony and
like this
the the hotel like it was a motel part
of that hotel
the motel security like came rolling up
and you're like
you like jumped off the balcony or you
jumped off like the the
second story thing and you're like it's
cool dude and you did like a press up to
handstand like
like like that dress up to hand stand
explained why it was cool that we were
like still like running around
and he's like um he's like oh yeah dude
i've met you before i bought you you did
backflip i bought you drinks at a bar
um after you did a backflip or something
like that right you know
the guy actually met you it was funny
though but um
and um then the next day we bonded over
a conversation about
porn um we were both we were talking
about how
um we didn't care we didn't lesbian porn
didn't do much for us
because um we agreed that it was like
looking at skateboard magazine and just
looking at skate spots with no one
riding them
right right i still feel that way don't
you oh a hundred percent
funny i love lesbian porn i mean dude
lesbian porno scenes in the porno it's
like how we used to deal with the virt
scenes you know
like yeah just fast forward that it's
fine
it's fine to see naked ladies but but
it's like
i don't know it's yeah it's like it's
like looking at a bunch of skateparks
with no one riding them right
like i wouldn't say a closed skatepark
but
just escape a skatepark maybe in the
rain yeah
i remember to after we ate at that diner
and we were on the long walk back to the
hotel
um you were kind of telling me what
jackass was gonna be like
like what our roles were you said uh
knoxville's gonna do a bunch of stuff
like every episode and each of the rest
of us will get like one
like one bit you know we're gonna be
kind of you know and i had no idea what
it was gonna be like
and so we did bond in that regard like
there was sort of a
a kinship of being um what do you call
it like supporting cast members
and um as soon as the show came out so
that i move out to california
we both happen to be homeless this is
one of my favorite things about our
history
the way that we competed to see who
could stay homeless for the longest
yeah it was awesome we uh we saved a lot
i mean i
i know i yeah we saved a lot of money on
rent and and just i mean
there was no reason to have a residence
like that was one of the funnest times
ever
where were you living chris at the time
wherever we were yeah i mean
he did mtv cribs out of his car i
remember that was the [ __ ] greatest
thing of all time
but were you actually living in your car
then i remember seeing that be like
there's no way
oh it wasn't like i'd go to sleep in my
truck every night but like some
i i mean i i did sleep in my truck
sometimes but but
mostly just stay where i was vagabond
how long did this go on for
we were couch surfers okay how long who
won
i didn't rent a place for probably eight
years
eight years pontius pontius won by a lot
i was too much of a drug addict you know
it was too much work to like
to like post up and do [ __ ] cocaine
for three days in a row when you didn't
have a home base
yeah you know the nomadic [ __ ]
cocaine is just no fun so i tapped out
and got an apartment and just
[ __ ] holed up and did drugs man
yeah you got one of those apartments
that has the big phone number like on
the side
like side of the building because uh
i guess it's easy to rent hollywood's so
we it's such a
a like a transient place like
like so many people come and go you know
they come with big
it is true they come with big dreams and
a lot of those people with big dreams i
met
like at your house
like yeah going through those old videos
of steve's old house there'd be like a
like a
an older dude in a suit sitting on a
couch next to a gangster and you're like
what the [ __ ] is
fair-weathered friends
are you from california originally chris
yeah i
am from san luis obispo right yeah and i
mean
i i the the way i mean i i work for big
brother magazine for
for years i was kind of that's how i got
involved with jackass and
i i i was one i was kind of on a path my
whole life
like you know going in a direction
and i didn't really know where it was
going but i would you know it started
with like
you know traveling around being a skater
kind of like stevo was i'm sure
in a way but but then you know big
brother then we started making videos
and then it turned into tv it just
evolved and
i just kind of stayed on the same path
and just kind of see
gone where my destiny took me you know
but i wasn't like where i wanted to like
the goal was to become like
a famous dude so i think that kind of
allowed me to
like walk in and out of different lives
a lot like
i never got so invested in you know
hollywood and stuff like that you know
i've got a lot of friends in a lot of
different worlds
you know so i i just wanted to travel
basically and
make my life an adventure really so you
you know
you traveled i definitely had absolutely
yeah you traveled a lot before you
uh got famous oh yeah just traveling
around the world was my goal in life and
and if whatever job i had you know i
i just wanted it to be you know you know
get to incorporate that into and that's
kind of like when we made up wild boys
at the end of the jackass series um
it was like that was like me and jeff
germain both were obsessed with animals
and and
i always had a dream of having my own
nature show like um because when i was a
kid i liked
mutual of omaha's wild kingdom and i
loved animals like when i was a little
kid i wanted to go live in the jungle
and like like live in the treetops like
that's what i wanted to do
like i wanted to be like like
like that's what i wanted can you can
you uh
remind me of what it was you had like
some awesome
uh arrest report like like you got
arrested
in australia like yeah
man i love pontius i could just about
say that he's my favorite dude on
jackass
and you know what else i can say that my
favorite sponsor
of this podcast is hellotushy.com
i mean i'm telling you they make this
bidet
right that's built onto my toilet
and after i get done taking a big sloppy
dump before i even think about wiping
as i'm sitting there i turn this knob
right
and blast right into my
butthole man and it cleans it like a
pressure cleaner
you know actually i think i'm gonna
treat myself to a little blast right now
yeah oh yeah i love it man
turn up the power a little bit oh yeah
and you know i'm clean as could possibly
be
then i grab a little bit of toilet paper
really just to dry it off
and for the satisfaction of seeing that
there
is no poo on the toilet paper man
if you were going to be covered in poo
would you want to wipe it off with a dry
paper towel
or would you want to take a shower it's
that simple
hellotushy.com to blast your
butthole to perfect cleanliness
and it's my favorite of any sponsor of
this podcast i say that proudly
i want you to try it so
you go to dot hellotushy.com
slash stevo and you get ten percent off
your order
it's my favorite thing i absolutely
cannot stand the idea of pooping
without my hello tushy so there you go
get ten percent off yours at
hellotushy.com
stevo now let's hear about pontius
getting in trouble
yeah i in australia what are you doing
in 1999 i just went i i had
i saved up a little bit of money and i
figured i'd i'd get there and i'd meet
some skaters and
and make friends with them and and you
know just kind of
see what happened because i always
wanted to go to australia so i went
there and sure enough i met
i met um skaters the first day i got
there i went to bondi beach and
that was kind of like the mecca of
australian skateboarding at the time
because there was the ramp on the beach
and and i made a bunch of friends and
and um
then i i bought a bus ticket where i
could just travel up the coast
and stop in any town and then you could
get back on the bus and i got to this
place
early beach and um i was with a friend
that i met on the way and
i we got drunk one night and uh on red
bulls and whiskey
and um then i guess um he just he went
home eventually
and um i i think i was in a weird mood
that might that night or something
next thing i knew i i was being woken up
by a police officer in jail
he's like you want to get up now and i'm
you know i was like
i looked around i realized i'm in jail
he's like it's 11 o'clock
and i'm like what did i do and he's like
you got caught with a 14 year old girl
mate and i'm like what
he's like just kidding
you know then he told me like what i did
do was i
i like um i was in a
i ended up going into like a part of a a
resort that was being under construction
and um i broke this i i think i got
locked in part of the building or stuck
in it
and i broke through this giant like
safety glass window
and i was smashing at it wearing just
surf trunks no shoes
nothing like that and the security was
on the other side like trying to like
like mellow me out but they couldn't get
into me
and but i wouldn't mellow out and i
smashed through it and i jumped through
and they grabbed me
and um and then you know eventually the
eventually the police arrived in
you know they handed me over to the
police but in australia
they don't it's not like america where
they automatically handcuff you
they in australia they just put you in
the car and um
so they put me in the car they should
have handcuffed me
yeah so according to police report they
put me in the police car and then went
to go talk to witnesses
while they were talking to witnesses i
kicked i kicked through the police car
window
and went to make my escape barefooted
but they quickly caught up with me
you know you know after a bit of after
some struggle
you know i was thrown in jail and then
so
how many that's like basically you know
how many the police report says so
so when i was talking to the cop he's
like um he told me what i did um
he's like um i was like oh man i felt
terrible about it i'll go apologize to
the manager of the resort
and i apologize profusely to the police
and still i just had surf trunks on
those shoes
so then i had to walk a few miles into
town and on like
super hot asphalt and i went straight to
the resort um and i
apologized to the lady and she's like oh
i felt so bad we saw the footage of you
you know
it was terrible and i was like um
do you think i could get that footage
um you know i i got i got the contacts
but i was never able to get it but i uh
you know in my mind
at the time i thought i thought it would
come in handy and i knew there was an
idea
going on with big brother you know of
something you know what became jackass
but
but anyway they didn't press charges and
the police
didn't press charges because like there
was like assaulting the police
destruction of property this and that
you know and you know
the police i i ended up winning their
hearts and they didn't press charges so
um i had to go to court like a few days
later and
in court i stood up in front of you know
there was other criminals there
like you know doing their cases so i was
explaining my situation i had a public
defender and
you know like i was telling my story and
like other like the other people like
in the courtroom were like laughing and
they were like basically i was they were
like well no one wants to press charges
if you pay for all your damages you know
you can go on your way and you know they
gave me like a year of probation in
australia
and you know that the incident ended up
paying for itself in spades because i
wrote an article in big brother about
it i wrote an article in like maxim or
fhm about it
um i got to talk about it on different
tv shows i'm even talking about it now
like it was totally worth it but at the
at the time when i first got out of jail
i felt really bad
like i was i felt really bad about
myself because i didn't have a lot of
money at the time like
so like and yeah whatever you know a
thousand dollars worth of damages was a
big deal
yeah um and i didn't know like what was
like i didn't know like if i was gonna
have to go to jail for more for more
because i mean
those were some bad charge i mean bad
enough charges
but um but yeah it ended up being fine
but
all the experience of life sorry for
rambling on that's an amazing story it'd
be cool if like somebody listening can
make a cartoon out of that story
you know and send it over to you that'd
be that'd be epic plus trust me
everybody's thinking
thank god it's not stevo rambling on
yeah i'm surprised this evening tell
that story for you
right so what about the time
when we were in miami and uh you got
found on the roof of the parked suv
butt naked with your clothes neatly
folded and
like laying on the curb and you were
just dead asleep and they woke you up
and then and did you did you try to
fight those cops
i i did i did threaten them i don't
think
oh yeah i think i did try to fight them
because yeah they did mace me oh
oh you know i think you had a killer
police report on that one too
yeah and he said that i said i'll kick
your posterior
i know i didn't say that but they they
said claim that i did
but yeah i did start a fight with him of
course
i i mistook the roof of that suv for my
hotel room
yeah i was i was on fire that night well
i think i mixed the wrong potions yeah
i think you and i hadn't seen each other
for a little while and and
we got a little carried away oh i
remember i remember it well i remember
it well
and uh you know to be clear you were
never
uh a fan of cocaine you just didn't you
weren't you weren't into it it was you
know i was the one who wanted to do
cocaine all the time
but i did cocaine so much that it really
became a problem and i vowed to
to stop doing it you know i i gave up
cocaine
and and i had made it six months
without doing cocaine and then when we
were reunited in miami
for some unbeknownst reason pontius says
i've got a hankering for some booger
sugar
i don't know why i think it's because we
were in miami right you know
it just felt right but it was so wrong
do you know where you can get good cook
in florida
yeah glad you asked the bartender
at the bar in the hotel that we were
setting that provided some
yeah and that's all it took to kick me
off the wagon
i was like oh okay okay
you know want us to know something weird
about that story so
for anyone that doesn't know um yeah i
after a night on the town
i ended up um being found by the police
sleeping naked on an suv
but i later found out that tripp
taylor's friend
um talked to him and he said he was
going home and he saw me
sleeping on an suv naked and he took my
clothes and to
take them into his um and he was going
to come back out and get me
but then when he came back out i was
gone which some there's some shady
business
i think he was playing a joke on me and
just took my clothes because
and my everything everything like
everything was gone all i had was was my
birthday suit
what god gave me all i have is what god
gave me to get out of that mess
i love it in that story the problem is
that that guy
pulled a joke on me
that guy the problem was that that guy
undressed pontius
you strike me as somebody that like
blacks out drunk in someone's house and
like wakes up in the middle of night and
pee's in the corner of their living room
thinking it's the bathroom
have you ever done it yeah like a a bad
version of that
yeah like um i think i was just
uh i sometimes i get in the mood to
really push things
like that in a so but that time honestly
i think i just
drank too much and did whatever else
ended up going in my body that night and
in them and i really did think the suv
was my
was my hotel room and and um
and um so when the police arrived on the
scene you know
i was really grumpy to be woken up and
so i guess i did start a fight with them
and
and um they ended up pepper spraying me
i just remem like
man i mean you've probably pepper
sprayed yourself steve
i've poured a lot of hot sauce in my
eyes even my own brand of hot sauce
which is called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and it's now available on amazon
yeah give it five stars it's that good
it's available on prime but for all the
hot sauce i've poured in my eyes i've
never been
red pepper sprayed i have it's it's
awful and there are different levels of
it but um
but um yeah it stopped me it
it it stopped me dead in my tracks and
i'm really like when i'm fired up i'm
pretty hard to stop
and but um yeah it stopped me i i i
panicked i couldn't breathe i couldn't
see
um i was like i i was the like putty in
the police's hands at that point
i think i started crying well i was
crying of course i was it was pepper
spraying my eyes
and um so they thought i was crazy
and um so that instead of taking me to
jail they took me to the hospital
and i ended up like in in like the
mental part of it and like
i couldn't remember the name the name of
the hotel was some crazy spanish name
that
they didn't roll off the tongue so i
couldn't remember what hotel we were at
you know and i had this weird orderly in
there and he was like nurse ratchet
and he's like i was frustrated because
because the police were
total gentlemen but like um this guy was
just like giving me a hard time and
and i was frustrated because i couldn't
remember the name of the hotel and he's
like
it looks seems like you need a valium um
somebody like
you're a little wound up somebody needs
a valium and i'm like why do you think i
got here in the first place
i mean it freaked me the guy was i i
guarantee you he was one of those
like mental ward like psychos that like
abuses people like
geez you know yeah and i so i had a gap
they
i had of course when i was brought in i
had no clothes on so they'd give me a
gown
but the gown like it was like
three sizes too small so like my butt's
totally hanging out
it was terrible so when i got back to
the hotel you know like
it when i first when i checked in the
night or the night before like they
treated me like a total gentleman they
called me mr pontius
and there was like a complimentary
bottle of champagne for me to enjoy
while i
was in the bubble bath dude it was the
nicest hotel
we were there we were there to present
an award at the
latin vmas and we had like palatial
[ __ ] hotel suites at this like
super south beach hotel on like collins
it was uh one of the more obnoxious big
like gaudy hotel rooms that we'd ever
done and pontius chose to sleep on the
roof of vanessa
yeah i didn't belong there a lot a lot
of times like when
along this this period of like being on
tv you know i
we end up in a lot of places we don't
belong like like
in in i've always like a lot of times
made it known that i didn't belong there
like
ever whenever i've been like given the
chance to give out an award you know
um like at the european um vmas oh my
god
that was terrible i wasn't there for
that one but uh
but you gotta tell that story man
chris really did something pretty messed
up and you're gonna hear about it
after this important message about
your balls okay now listen here guys
testicular cancer is the number one form
of cancer in men
aged 15 to 35. all right
and manscaped one of my favorite
products i've ever promoted on this
podcast
has teamed up with the testicular cancer
society
to save your balls okay
we need to let you know how important it
is to check your balls once a month
and that means grab your nuggets in a
nice hot shower roll them back and forth
between your fingers if you feel
anything funky
you contact your doctor right away okay
and while you're down there
fondling your nuggets how about a good
look at what's going on
with with your hairdo down there do you
need grooming
because i'm guessing you do and that's
why manscaped is so
important gentlemen get your grooming
products
they make the best ball trimmer in the
world
okay it's called the lawnmower 3.0 and
if you
get a little older and you got hair
growing out of your nose and your ears
you get the manscaped weed whacker you
take care of it no
problem for that that really upsetting
ball smell you get the manscaped ball
deodorant
they got the best grooming products and
i want you to try them
by going to manscaped.com
stevo you're not only going to get 20
off your order if you go to manscape.com
you're going to get free shipping too
so get to it check your balls and groom
them up
all right now let's hear about this
terrible thing pontius did
nick dunlap convent convinced me to do
it like so
what was the award that you were giving
the award was for best artist
and the actual winner was the white
stripes no the actual winner was
coldplay
but um nick dunlap got the idea to like
say like
um it was when like um everyone was mad
at metallica or something like for
for um busting napster yeah napster
stuff in
in um so he's like oh what if he'd say
it's for metallica but then
and then they come up and then be like
oh sit no it's not you guys sit down
um it's coldplay and then they're all
like oh the only band that's actually
here is the white stripes and so then
nick as nick can i was like i really
like the white stripes i don't want to
do that to them and then
as we drank a little bit you know nick
nick basically convinced me to do it you
know i don't blame him i did it but
you know so it was time to give out the
award and he opened up the envelope and
had said coldplay open up the envelope i
say and the winner is the white stripes
and they played that night and
everything which was it was awesome
and i was into the white stripes like
before they were big i saw them play at
little places like i was hardcore into
them
like um from way before and in them
you know and then so i actually gave
everyone time to cheer for them
and like they walked halfway through
stage and stuff and then i'm like
just kidding it's coldplay oh god
i immediately felt so bad but pontius
lifelong regret was that he didn't just
stick to his guns and give the [ __ ]
thing
have you ran into them since the thing
is i didn't even think about that that i
should have just given it to them
that would have been such a baller move
to be like no i think for the white
stripes
it didn't even come up until like weeks
later like oh you should have given the
award to them
like right oh god and so i ran into meg
white later that night
and um i was like i was like oh i'm so
sorry
um you know and her her like security
guy wanted to like
fight me and yeah i knew i like or he
was he didn't like me
but um but meg was super cool i ended up
talking to her for like hours
and um jack wasn't there but um i i
apologize so much and we had a great
conversation got along famously
but um she was super cool and but she's
like it wouldn't have been a big deal
but
we were halfway to the stage
that's so gnarly dude but basically i
did that because i didn't belong there
like i was always like like you know i
didn't like the mainstream stuff like i
was like
um you know whatever you know
who cares is stupid awards you know if
the white stripes guy
that guy was all about being like punk
rock you know like and he later became
pretty mainstream himself i guess but
you know they were rad
and it was that was mean of me to do
but i should have given them the award
so i would like if they
i don't know if they listen to your
podcast but if they do
um i i would like them to know that that
i wish i would have given them the award
and they were the best band of the year
in my eyes
yeah for sure it's shocking that they
didn't have the award to begin with
i know it is it really is um speaking of
things that that
awful things that were nick dunlap's
idea
ah how about when we were at the
download festival
and somehow i told this story to
jonathan davis the lead singer of corn
about how at the download festival like
before we got off stage
whoever the next band is throw all these
eggs and we gave out like hundreds of
crates of eggs do you remember
trying to get in a fight with uh oh the
electric six
yeah yeah well like um so i think
it it was a shortened set because it was
a festival show and so
you were going to like have like someone
from the audience get egg but then
it couldn't happen so you told them that
egg the next band and
it happened to be the electric six thank
god it wasn't pennywise
which was the band apparently i took six
we knew them but they would have kicked
our asses
and and also like i mean i was friends
with some of them
but um but anyway so is the electric six
and and
from my point of view like what i wasn't
it
there but i guess they got egged in and
it was pretty gnarly like the whole time
and um the guy you you came up to me and
you told me like exactly
this guy threw a beer on me except it
landed on my girl
i was handling the girl i had a date
with me and he threw beer on me
but he got it on my girl and i told
chris
he tell you the truth that girl was kind
of a [ __ ] but but
he disrespected you and in my eyes he
started trouble with with my friend
in
are you telling the truth like you're
not lying about this right because
if you're if you're if you tell me that
this really happened and and
it's true then i'll address this matter
yeah like as whenever anyone would like
would stick me on somebody
like as long as it like like there's
been a few times like yeah where like
you know like um a friend of mine or a
female friend would like
be harassed you know and and you know
and want something
you know something would need to be done
about it but yeah you were serious you
were distraught
yeah absolutely definitely serious
luckily i had my wrestling singlet on
like under my clothes so you put yeah
i put my wrestling singlet on and i went
i went to up to them
into their whole trailer he said i want
to fight all six of you but the electric
six it's not six guys
yeah i want to fight all six of you and
uh and the guy the guy opens up the
curtain just
like a little bit and pawnee is punches
through the glass now pontius is
bleeding everywhere
and then they send all the festival
security to come over and they [ __ ]
locked us
in our trailer well we just couldn't get
out so we just start peeing all over it
like
breaking breaking everything they they
put um they
when when i started like um you know
telling that
trying to start a fight with the
electric six they put them into a
trailer that trailer though
and wanted them just to like get
distance from me and then
so then at the window like the guy the
guy he antagonized me he opened the
blinds
he flipped me off he gave me a taste of
his middle finger
i never knew you were such like a
scrapper chris like did you grow up like
wrestling and fighting like where'd you
even
i wouldn't have any confidence to try
and fight a whole band you know like
well um yeah i mean i'm not really i'm
not like
where i'm from actually like um it
growing up fist fighting seemed like a
really important thing
to to be able to do i don't know why it
just
is it's not like some overly rough town
people seem to be into fighting a lot
like it was something to do i guess
i think the common denominator in all of
the fighting stories is a little
bit of liquid courage in in those ones
but there's other ones
like a lot of times um i mean i i've
been in lots of fist fights
like with with multiple people like you
know like
i was at the amateur finals of the skate
contest that i was in
when i was like 18 or 19 and um i was
dancing i was
it was i was like outside and i was like
doing that dance or something and some
guy walked by and he's like you better
not be doing that to my girlfriend
and my friend who was a troublemaker was
like you mean your hooker or something
like that
and um um whatever like i i barely even
like heard him say it but
later on like like 10 guys came out of
the building and like
pointing at me like they're like that's
the [ __ ] and like um
i'm like and my friend who had said it
like was nowhere to be seen and i'm like
oh [ __ ] these guys are gonna
kick my ass so like um
i think one one guy punched me and i was
gonna just let him do it and like
in in a you know because i didn't want
to fight like eight i think was eight
people and
and and then um my friends like he
didn't even say anything and
my friend scott you know scott that we
work with and he's got scott
and blood went flying and and i was like
[ __ ] all you guys and i started fighting
them
in them i i um
now i'm just telling fight stories but i
i just the guy was cocky and
they were real jerks and i headbutted
this dude as hard as i could like six
times until his nose was flat
and then i like jumped on him to smash
his head into the concrete and his
friend ran up
with like and kicked me in the head and
that got me off and then they took off
and um i was in lots of like brutal
fights like when i when i was younger
like
i think i was just like um i was bigger
than some of my friends so like when
someone would no i'm not even that big
but when someone would start i'd always
be
have to be the guy that that hey chris
pitbulls aren't that
big that's right but but
like a lot of times when i if i i don't
really like
fighting but but i would be laughing
like it wouldn't it would
not i wouldn't even be serious about it
but like when i was a kid
like i got jumped a few times like by
like multiple people when i was little
like 14
like like you know when people hated
skaters like in the 80s
like i i'm glad the world's not like
this anymore but like
in the 80s like skateboarders were sold
misfits and and like
you know you'd be skating a parking lot
at night and like people would drive by
and like
be like [ __ ] you you suck you know and
maybe start fights with you and
i got i remember one time like a car
drove by and like
tried to run my friend over and and um
and then
like i then i thought the guys knew my
friend and and
it was a joke but then my friends took
off and then all these like
adults like surrounded me and like
they're like did you flip me off man
and i was like no and then like they
then they beat me up and like broke my
teeth and
things like that make you like that
happen to you in life they make you
tougher
yeah you know in the end you don't get
tough by winning fights
but how about i mean eventually
eventually you can but
but i mean i was a kid like like like
14 like getting beat up by adults you
know and
but those things in the end they do make
you stronger how about it do you believe
that
that we're middle-aged men now
looking looking back on your guys wild
boy career what what what stands out
what country
stands out to you guys i mean the the
the burning down of the three
cabins is always gonna be like uh that
was africa
kicking off kicking off the show yeah
that was the start right
yeah yeah to me i don't know everywhere
was rad
like it was everyone's an intense era
man like the wild boys
era was just like wow man so much life
experience
packed into like whatever it was three
years
and uh it was a lot of work how many
countries in three years
i don't know um i mean we had double
passports though like
like our passports like were filled up
so then
yeah yeah we had to have double pages
and those got filled up like
and then i got the third set of pages
yeah oh my god one time
during wild voice stevo was was showing
off his passport to me how many
um like this was in the middle of wow
boys like see i've got double pages and
like
he's showing me how full it is i'm like
i know dude i'm i was with you
yeah that's so funny
was the poo condom only on wild boys or
was that other was that jackass too
ah it was wild boys yeah
we didn't go like did we you weren't
doing that on your
on your own tour steve where you'd
swallowed dress i didn't go anywhere i
wouldn't be able to get drugs like
swallowing condoms full of weed
was only only for going anywhere in the
west or the eastern hemisphere
so everybody had to do it right he no
no not everyone's home but but steve
would get really grumpy if he didn't
have it
yeah like in indonesia i remember you
were really grumpy really grumpy we were
there for
three [ __ ] weeks dude couldn't smoke
pop for three weeks i was
not happy i want to bring i want to ask
steve something because i
i saw a clip that came up and i don't
know if it's going to bring up anything
you know bad for you but i remember
seeing you in india
so pissed off at a certain when they
were doing the sex thing
and was that because why was that
because you only saw clips of you like
dude you guys were just [ __ ] pissing
me off
right it's i i don't mind to be you see
wild boys was super homoerotic
we just got a real kick out of wearing
g-strings
and uh and like doing like you know
homosexually suggestive
stuff because we felt that like the
the macho sort of jock like you know
like homophobic people we we
loved the idea of getting a rise out of
them we were pushing our culture we were
ahead of our time
but i told the all the guys i was like
hey guys that that's it man like
there's no like uh no more gay stuff so
the first thing they put you in was the
gay stuff
right and uh and and like for the rest
of wild boys
he was having an inner struggle for the
rest of wild boys like it became a thing
like the movie airplane like
looks like i picked the wrong week to
quit acting games
that's funny he'd be like not into
acting and then like
then the next day like he'd do something
super gay but
it's weird like it's just dynamics of
like when it's two dudes
filming it just happens like even on
robin big like
there was like a lot of like homo ra
like you know like jokes
like it just happens i think the dynamic
of
two guys you know traveling around
together but it was funny like
something right but at the time yeah it
was it was ahead of its time and now it
would be totally cool
but you know the world wasn't as
accepting of a place
like just that short time ago you know
as it is now
and you know um sometimes i've watched
i've watched an episode of
wild boys and i think to myself god that
wasn't gay enough
and then i hear like mtv's notes or like
um some
other people we work with to be we gotta
tone down the gay thing they think we
got a tone on the gay stuff and i was
like i watched that same episode
i thought it wasn't gay enough i i
remember uh
that i want to say it was like right
after wild boys came out
my dad and i were in florida
went to the skate shop and there were a
couple kids skating outside the shop
and i just kind of like walked by
proudly
sort of displaying myself like thinking
all these kids these kids are gonna
recognize me
my dad's gonna be like proud of his son
you know
i'm walking by like kind of proudly and
and the one skater kid
right in front of my dad the one skater
kid says uh
to the other one yo dude that's the guy
for wild boys
and the other guy doesn't even look up
he goes those dudes are gay
that's funny dude yeah you know what all
the all that stuff was
funny like and i was like i was just
like who cares what people think like
it's funny like and and now we all like
like it's just whenever you know we were
pushing it
like oh my god dude tell us like uh
about the
what was the there was like a gay
magazine or a gay
online website and they were like
talking about jackass and how like
it was such a hit uh was saying that
yeah it said like knoxville of course is
the most
the best uh the best looking of the
jackass boys
but stevo seems to be the most likely to
uh you know just to suck your dick if
you got him drunk enough
i think it was like village voice yeah
that it said basically
roughly exactly that oh my god
you guys seem to have that chemistry
from the start because i've uh when you
when you were doing the flip into the
elephant [ __ ] that was one of the first
bits we filmed
yeah you guys barely kind of had even
known each other but you guys are like
showering together
in that well we were stuck we were
strapped for time
[Laughter]
it was just all the skies there like but
but really like
a long time ago before jackass i
realized like whatever you do it's going
to be way funnier if you're naked
like oh yeah 100 it basically comes down
to that like and
unfortunately on tv you can't be totally
naked so the g-string is the closest
you know you can legally get but i mean
g-strings are just rad
um even though i always preferred the
more conservative brazilian cut
brazilian kind are awesome too
they are that was with the cheese
because people always say oh you're
you're leopard print
thong no to cheetah brazilian
man is that exactly what it is
brazilian cut especially if your butt's
not like up to snuff
like maybe maybe uh if it's not in shape
as good a shape as you'd like it to be
the brazilian cuts can be very
flattering
yeah you know and and uh as as you can
see on any woman at the beach you know
wearing one
you know um but if you but
you know it's funny i i found out i
looked up um
thongs or g-strings and it it's the
first article of clothing that man
ever wore wow you know you know yeah
the original it's yeah like these thing
basically
you know basically keep the elements out
especially if you're
a woman i am i assume but um but yeah
it's
i mean or if you're a man it just for
the the most basic
article of clothing is the g string
there you go you know
and yes but i i think um yeah it was
just
whatever you do doing it naked it just
makes it ten times funnier
and yeah you know and if you're just
because cooler
a lot of stuff that we did i don't i i
i like and feel like people were so
worried about like being
people thinking that they were gay like
in it
you know at different times or back then
more than they are now
because of trailblazers like us i mean
i'd like to think that
we are a part of like opening like
people's minds a little bit you know
right i would say that that's fair to
give you guys some credit at least for
kind of
pushing that envelope for like for my
generation we grew up watching you guys
do all your gay [ __ ] on tv
we single-handedly we single-handedly
rid the world of homophobia
you fixed it single-handedly
[Laughter]
together holding hands together
chris oh go ahead no that's all you paul
well i was just curious how long were
you with big brother before
jackass um i i
i basically i started the first thing i
did
in big brother was like when i was 18
and then
so um and then i i left big brother like
at the beginning of jackass so eight
years wow
i i was so you were there before
knoxville was there
oh yeah way before and i mean i watched
big documentary i mean it
seems like that like was that the glory
days or was jackass the glory days
ah they were just different days like
they they
i mean big brother was was like this
thing that
there you know you couldn't have jackass
without big brother because
big brother was like a magnet to all the
misfits in the skateboard world because
when big brother started i mean as you
saw from that documentary skateboarding
was in a really weird place
and uh and uh so big brother just kind
of
like i mean like they found stevo you
know like it just
kind of brought together all these like
weird people like that were
maybe not necessarily pro skaters but
they were involved in the skateboard
world and and
you know and big brother like you know
gave them the platform
we had uh i mean it basically exactly
did that
we had ryan sheckler on and uh i was
telling the
story about going to the big brother
premiere in new york city
and and how like watching the big
brother documentary and seeing it all
put together
like it was it was jarring i've felt
like man like
like where jackass is kind of wholesome
and and in a good spirit you know like
we never like
we're never mean when we do [ __ ] to
ourselves but it wasn't that way with
big brother you know
like big brother it was almost like kind
of evil
and after the sheckler podcast came out
i got i got an angry text from rick
gossick
no way oh god oh god i bet yeah what did
you say
i mean he just said like hey man you
know like it seems like every chance you
get you you really uh
trash big brother magazine you know like
they were and they they were the ones
who discovered you you know you should
show some gratitude and uh i might think
i worked it out i told him like hey man
you know it's not like uh i'm putting
down big brother to make me
feel better if anything i think it's
just that the growth
of us you know like back back then we
were like sort of just finding our way
and it was like just oh
that would be shocking that it didn't
matter it didn't matter it was mean
it didn't matter if it was like just
really like wrong
you know but like as we grew up as we
found our way
we became like you know like guys who
want to do the right thing and i'm proud
of you you're absolutely right like yeah
big brother a lot of it was
about being naughty just being naughty
and also like
a lot of skateboard world didn't like
big brother like and we didn't like them
like in
in um yeah it was you're i think he
misunderstood you
yeah we worked it out at first i was i
was drafting a nasty response
to my to my good friend rick kasich i
was i was doing about it while riding
my bicycle i was thinking i'm going to
give him i'm
going to write him a strongly worded
letter
by the time i got around by the time i
got around to responding i was just like
hey dude man i'm sorry if that upset you
but
like i just think you know i look on it
this way
was jackass ever considered to be called
big brother like at the
beginning of like oh we're gonna make a
tv show what did anyone think like let's
call it big brother the show
or early on like when because you know
we made a few skate videos like every
once in a while
you know jeff would bring up you know
the idea of big brother basically it was
like big brother tv
but i don't it was going to be called
big brother because there was already a
show called big brother right right okay
you know and that kind of eventually
that
big brother tv idea because like spike
jones had
gotten big in like the the movie world
and in commercial world
and and um stuff so we had some
connections with hollywood and
um i and then like the knoxville who was
already pursuing being an actor and
offered a show with mtv
you know it that whole those ideas got
kind of mixed together from
from what i understand and um you know
that's what
you know big brother tv ended up
becoming jackass
or whatever but you know there's a lot
of different elements that
that you know make the whole and i think
everyone that
was a member of jackass you know is is
put like something invaluable to it you
know like
everyone's you know put their thing into
it that
you could it couldn't be jackass without
you know for sure
and then you know what what they brought
into it influenced the others you know
i mean i was never into doing stunts but
then i found myself doing stunts you
know
yeah you know and and it could just be
it everything takes a life of its own
you know once you get started
as wild boys did you know originally you
know at the beginning it was like it's
going to be this nature show and then
and then it crashed into its own thing
it gradually morphed back into jackass
yeah it did especially when knoxville
started
like we would have never made a second
movie if it wasn't for wild boys because
knoxville started just going on every
trip with us like
we went on like three in a row like and
then jeff was like if you're going to go
on every trip
like wow why don't we just make a movie
i remember when we had
when they had that conversation we were
in russia at some anti-terrorist
facility training compound and they had
a
like a [ __ ] attack dog they had a
nine millimeter gun with rubber bullets
they had all this like
[ __ ] he's the nachos like okay i'll
run through the [ __ ]
you know like uh this obstacle course
while the dog's attacking
me and you [ __ ] shoot me with the
nine millimeter while the dog's
attacking me
but he wanted it all to happen at once
oh yeah
and uh and jermaine said if you still
have this in you
let's not [ __ ] leave it on basic
cable
you know let's make a [ __ ] movie
totally
yeah yeah when did stevo come into the
picture for wild boys because you said
you and tremaine had the idea
was it were like yeah when did stevo
come into the picture for that
oh immediately like i mean okay when
when
you know it was it was never going to be
like just me like on some things like
yeah let's it was always going to be the
two of us
immediately yeah immediately um because
we wanted to like
do a show together anyway and i remember
we we were
talking about it uh while we were still
homeless which means
yeah before before the uh the first
movie yeah before the in in um and then
before it's jeez yeah and then before
the second movie we were gonna do it and
then
wait no no no you're yeah that was yeah
yeah you said it right sorry i confused
it
yeah before the first movie we we wanted
to do it and then the movie happened
my my question is like you guys are
filming with sharks or crocodiles or
gorillas or whatever right
and you're like oh [ __ ] okay this is
going to be gnarly how much
value and and safety do you feel that
manny's around
like when manny's there you're like oh
dude i got immunity
or like describe manny in your guy's
relationship and how
how much he helps you guys
like uh there's definitely a sense of
impunity like nothing can go wrong
because manny's there he's like a good
omen right like it's a false sense of uh
it's like a false sense of security
courage the first time i did something
with animal that first time i personally
did something
like gnarly with animals with manny we
went it was like during filming jackass
movie we had a weekend off
and so we went um me and jeff and and
bradley
and manny went to the swamp and to go
swi swim
with um allergies
i was talking we i've never done it you
know and and yeah like exactly where
people get eaten like
and i was talking to man i'm like so
what do we do if like something goes
wrong you know like
like you know we get attacked he's like
there's no plan b
hopefully that won't happen and like but
then you're with them
and you just for some reason feel safe i
don't know
not safe but i don't know i don't know
what it is remember when we were in
south africa
and uh the we were allowed to swim with
great white sharks outside of the cage
but only if we had this guy named andre
hartman
yeah and then we found out that andre
hartman like canceled
our plans because he's gonna film with
some rich japanese businessmen or
something
and uh he had to film with he the day
before he wasn't with us because he
had to film with with this like chic or
something yeah yeah
yeah oil tycoon or something so like so
so all of a sudden they said sorry boys
you you have to be in the cage
you know like with the to swim with the
sharks and we were getting drunk at the
bar
like the night before the shoot and i'm
like dude we're not doing i said when
they say that
they said we could jump off the boat
into the cage
and i said when when it's time to jump
chris
we we jump off the other side of the
boat we swim around it and then climb in
the cage
and we're like making a pact this guy
next to us at the bar
says if the great white shark finds you
swimming
it'll be curious and bite you and then
you'll bleed to death the safest thing
to do is jump on the shack
and that guy was andre hartman oh really
we were sitting next to him at the bar
what are the chances yeah we were
sitting next to him at the [ __ ] bar
and he got stoked yeah he's like dude i
[ __ ] like he hurt our whole
conversation or it's making the pact
we're gonna do that
and he just fell in love with us and he
[ __ ] canceled the sheik
it was back on it was all stormy and it
was like rough seas that day so there
was no other boats out
so the sharks get spread kind of thin
with like too many boats chumming
so we were just out there by ourselves
um yeah
our android was right i remember in the
clip he's like there's like birds
chirping he's like they're saying
there's a shark over there
i mean great white sharks remember when
we like we're swimming with the seals
and the shallows
and we got out of the water and like
we were swimming like near the the shore
of that island it just drops off really
quick i guess but
we right when we get back in the boat
like some giant shark goes flying out of
the water like after sealing
yeah there's a chase that went on for
like quite a while
exactly where we had just been swimming
with seals and dressed
as seals
they're gnarly
what was that what was the line before
uh when
if you're ever out on the water and a
great white comes around whatever you do
get the hell out of the boat
[Laughter]
that's epic that's hartman no no no no
no that was what i was like
if you're ever if you ever you know uh
find yourself on a boat and a great
white shark approaches
save yourself jump up that boat
immediately
i remember when i was watching that
stuff as a kid i was like who's who's
writing all this you know they must have
like hilarious writers writing all these
lines for them because you guys are just
throwing out
gems like but you guys just came up with
all that right percent we've never had a
right natural reaction to the
to what's going on around us well we've
been like we've watched
yeah while setting up uh the shots you
know because they're
always setting up we'd be like okay
what's our intern gonna be what's our if
we just be cracking ourselves up
we do that to this day oh my god like
getting together with with with you like
recently and and uh coming up with funny
intros
dude it's just so funny i mean it warms
my heart so much
like just that that we that we're middle
age and we can still
[ __ ] do the same thing yeah it's
awesome
like getting old and we're still still
doing the same [ __ ] and
[ __ ] man i love it so much what uh
what's it like being a dad now
it's rad um it's awesome being a dad i
mean
i'm very busy um but um it's the best
thing ever like um
i just play with he's like my little
partner um
yeah it's the i don't know i mean anyone
that is also a dad
that's listening to this knows you know
it's the most amazing thing in the world
in in um yeah i mean it's it's changed
my life and
in i mean it's just it's everything's
different you know but in the in the
rattus way and
and i'm glad that that that i have a kid
with someone that i love and and
we have a great family together and and
you know everyone you know
um i i don't know like i'm just i'm
really like happy with my life
did you ever think you settled down and
have kids was that a part of the plan
yeah
yeah i always wanted to have kids but um
just
you know i was always off doing
something it it you know
i mean he's a modern-day caveman of
course he was gonna have kids
i didn't start pursuing having a kid
until
um you know we were ready to have like a
kid it was
um but um you know because there's a lot
you know
you can still travel and things like
that but it's just different so sure i
waited till i was ready you know
um and then it's a whole different type
of fun but yeah it's the raddest thing
ever
hey will you give me a second i'm going
to actually check out what hey dude
we've we've kept you
plenty long enough dude this is uh dude
but dude there's so much to talk about
like part two is gonna be yeah we're
gonna have this again
oh yeah yeah let's do more part and uh
okay so also the ufc has this thing
i told you about the watch party coming
up uh
and and it'll actually be like in in two
days from when this comes out
yeah um i told them they asked me
uh who am i thinking that i would have
as a guest you know to to
do it with me and i said it'd be great
to have chris pontius but
uh coveted testing's gonna be super
important you know he's got his baby and
stuff and like you know we've
got like uh so like
of the minimal people who are gonna be
here everybody's gonna
like be tested to come out that's right
i'm in yeah the main card starts at 11
a.m
but uh we gotta we gotta be ready and
shooting by the
featured prelim you know um i was and
they're making the house a bubble for it
how rad that's awesome i'm
so stoked on that and um you know what
um i
years ago um i was in a muay thai class
in san francisco
and um the teachers like took the class
aside he's like check out this video and
it
it would just come out it was um he had
a video of ufc
2 this is when it happened
like i i've known ufc since the very
beginning
and it was like whoa this is like um
[ __ ] bloodsport like style against
style like
i was actually in a martial arts class
when when
that first happened um and then wow it
became huge but yeah i i
i [ __ ] love it so yeah definitely
cruise on over because it starts at 11
like
you know i would say you got to get here
like 10 30 in the morning but it'll be
[ __ ] killer for us today that's right
because what's going to make it funny
it's going to make it rad is is just
the banter you know like hell yeah
that's awesome
i'm super stoked on that awesome well
[ __ ] chris
like uh love you dude we're going to
like love you guys too yeah
we're going to let you get back to that
family you know you guys have fun
thanks for having me on i had a great
time yeah i [ __ ] love you so much man
i really really do
i love you too and and and um yeah let's
do this again
all right dude i love it man thanks so
much chris later yeah
have fun be safe could pontius be any
better or awesomer of a dude i don't
know man i don't think so
um could you be any better or awesomer
for sticking around to the end of this
podcast
i don't think so and uh this week i
would love it if you did the thing where
you screenshot the podcast and post it
with pontius tagged
let him know how much you enjoyed it um
i just always appreciate that a lot
and i love that guy i also would really
appreciate it
if if you guys keep buying this stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole on
amazon with prime it's free shipping and
uh
we just like have a relationship with
amazon man we got to keep that stuff
like flowing man you know we stock it up
it's got to go we got to stock it up
again
and it's very small numbers that we're
doing so
i really appreciate your guys help man
and that's it dudes
i love you all thank you so much